bien alors vous êtes le dernier
président de l'urss prix nobel de la
paix en 1990 pour votre contribution
essentielle à la fin de la guerre froide
vous êtes à la tête du parti social
démocrate qui soutiendra sa marche pas
le son a paraît il disparaît alors ça va
pas du tout il faut qu'il faut qu'il
entende bien c'est pas une grève au
moins vous voulez être président de ce
pays
pour le moment ça va
donc vous êtes le dernier président de
l'urss prix nobel de la paix 1990 pour
votre contribution essentielle à la fin
de la guerre froide
vous êtes à la tête du parti social
démocrate qui soutiendra vladimir
poutine pour la prochaine élection
présidentielle
pour l'instant je n'ai donné vous l'avez
j'ai eu tout juste bien alors il y a dix
ans presque jour pour jour disparaissait
l'union soviétique et c'est vraiment
extraordinaire et je vous en remercie
encore de vous avoir avec nous ce soir
mais file gorbatchev
alors effectivement quand vous êtes
arrivé au pouvoir en urss vous à des
mortiers énormément avec la
gérontocratie qui régnait alors au
kremlin et vous imposer un new look au
pouvoir en urss
parce que d'abord vous êtes capable de
sourire ensuite vous avez ce qu'est rare
là bas quand même faut se souvenir
ensuite vous aviez une allure moderne et
votre épouse
notre cher raïssa était une véritable
first lady est ce que c'était votre
nature profonde où c'était une stratégie
politique sur notre nom c'est tout à
fait naturel
si on venait tout seul pourtant vous
aviez gravi tous les échelons du parti
communiste soviétique avec des gens qui
étaient pas drôle du tout et vous les
avez supporté pendant des années avec
cette nature là vous savez beaucoup de
gens qui étaient très sympathiques et
guy pavan et dénis sioniste tout seul je
n'aurais plus rien faire en ce moment là
j'aurais juste faire faire ce qui jusque
souvent tirés moi j'ai un peu préparé
l'émission aujourd'hui et donc j'ai une
question à poser comme je suis un prénom
j'ai prénom russe
donc j'ai une question à vous poser
manoubia patcher la vaste vaspart hausse
qui est ce que je peux vous faire un
baiser à la russe
vous voulez bien me battre et ça veut
dire commencer c'est quoi le visuel
aarhus part au ski à la russie
bois
est ce là je me tendait une proposition
de ce genre sur ma gauche et puis
l'oublier parce que moi je peux en faire
une devise à la russie alors il règne
leur 20e quand vous arrivez au pouvoir
vous arrivez avec trois nouveaux
concepts la pérestroïka la glace noces
et la nouvelle pensée diplomatique
nouvelle pensée diplomatique
c'est ralentir la course aux armements
qui était intenable pour un pays comme
l'urss qui allait assez mal sur le plan
économique la glace noces c'est la fin
du goulag la liberté de parole
il appelle eysseric à ses gardes et
l'idéal socialiste mais supprimer les
déviations du stalinisme
vous dites dans votre livre on peut dire
que le communisme total a subi une
défaite totale
est ce que cette idée que le communisme
total étaient mauvais pour la russie
vous l'aviez depuis longtemps ou est ce
que vous l'avez réaliser quand vous êtes
arrivé au pouvoir comme ici ce qui au
départ j'ai des communes et j'y croyais
et je crois en terminale j'ai adhéré au
parti communiste qu'on était en termine
et je suis restée partie pendant des
années et c'est quand j'étais au parc
quand j'ai commencé à faire de la
politique ou religieux
les jackets menaient d'information
d'informations plus je comprenais que ce
système ne fonctionne qu ils me
demandaient les mauvais cela dit j'avais
quand même désillusion je pensais que
j'arriverai améliorait les sirènes et
j'ai passé mes deux premières années et
noir et et quoi cela dit le modèle était
toujours là il était toujours une souris
jury
j'ai compris qu'il fallait le remplacer
ce n'est pas l'idée socialiste qui a
bien un échec et ma belle ainsi du
cubisme qui a été imposé par les
bolchéviques à la russie qui
dara l'échec cuisant c'est comme ça que
l'intéressé washington s'était 1948
alors allez peuvent vous voulez en
revenir à ce que disait le jeune marx
quand ils n'étaient pas encore partisans
de la dictature du prolétariat
bref vous voulez revenir à ce qu'on
appelle le communisme à visage humain
c'est-à-dire le socialisme mais vous
aviez ouvert la boîte de pandore et une
fois que vous avez donné quelques
libertés aux gens la glace note la
pérestroïka l'urss implose et vous en
perdez le contrôle
un petit peu comme en france louis saez
quand il a accepté la convocation des
états généraux et que la situation lui a
échappé est ce qu'aujourd'hui on ne vous
félicite pas pour quelque chose
non pas que vous avez fait mais que vous
n'avez pas pu empêcher ce moment là
j'aurais été secrétaire général du pc et
ça se joue à rien les choses mais quand
je suis monté au sommet à l'écart du
pouvoir revenir quand je suis devenu ça
ne l'est de ce pays qui est n 1 en
puissance et la hissent les deux rames
démenti qu'il y avait un seul guillaume
nusse nodal on a problem icloud pouvoir
eh bien j'ai commencé à dmitry pouvoir
démocratique commencé à rendre à le
couloir au peuple c'est et soeurs mu des
la démocratie l'ouverture agnès la
liberté cela fait bouger la russie tout
d'abord le monde
ensuite je savais rien je faisais nos
prix faisait en reconnaissant
et on peut dire que j'ai laissé agir les
l'histoire alors là effectivement à ce
moment là c'est le démantèlement du
rideau de fer entre la hongrie
la chute du mur de berlin la
réunification de l'allemagne
la disparition du pacte de varsovie et
en 1991 la chute de l'urss alors 1991
c'est l'année du putsch l'ailé dure du
parti communiste d'union soviétique
profite du fait que vous êtes en
vacances en crimée et le 19 août 91 à
7h20 du matin l'agent stas annonce que
vous êtes incapable d'assumer vos
fonctions pour raisons de santé
vous êtes remplacé par le vice président
qui s'appelle ianaïev l'état d'urgence
est déclaré les chats entre dans moscou
et bruxelles si n'appelle désobéissance
civile à la grève générale à ce moment
là françois mitterrand qui était
président de la république en france
tout de suite ce rallye
aliens et f vous en pensez quoi de ce
ralliement subi qui étaient considérés
ici en france comme une faute politique
président gilles moindrot eh bien je
pense de france même devant le président
milan mon ami qui est resté mon ami
jusqu'à la fin
simplement ils ne maîtrisaient pas
l'ensemble des informations aurait mis
un terme à ce qui s'est passé en réalité
un drogué me remercier tout comme les
autres les hommes politiques et la chine
y voici
tout comme en atteste avoir l'immense
majorité de la population russe
il a même envoyé son messager un
représentant de l'ambassade de france à
moscou qui est venu me voir en crimée à
foros vous n'avez jamais voulu d'avoir
rallié aussi rapidement les nerfs non
non non non jamais les chemises schwab
il ya des monstres présidient président
du pôle pharma stressant il simplement
qu un match riche en restant président a
eu des informations qu'il n'était pas
vraiment à qui il conseille à son jeu
démocratie animal le président tombe
gravement malade c'est les
vice-présidents qui prend le pouvoir
voudrait qu'il a compris que ce n'était
pas le cas
il a tout de suite reconnu et là donc
c'est un petit peu la russie contre
l'urss les putschistes sont arrêtés
boris elstine suspens le parti
communiste d'union soviétique le
parlement acquiesce vous démissionnez et
l'urss n'existe plus alors les
observateurs ont dit mikhaïl gorbatchev
que ce putsch avait été en fête
organisée par vous pour rétablir l'état
d'urgence et la censure sans ternir
votre image
nos primes a été shootée absolue
eh bien vous comprenez j'espère que si
un règlement absurde kazarama les autres
l'été de la saga vous voulez dire que jj
mandat j'ai vraiment commis québec
je voulais pas signer le nord à bruay du
noir de patrice tonda gabor est moniteur
la région du québec rytchkov a dit
demain ce sera trop tard
le traité l'union aurait fui ce sera
trop tard fois genres attirés
aujourd'hui le 19 août prochain que je
devais sur ces gens-là copier-coller
makouri en grèce qu'à partir du moment
où le nouveau traité de l'union sera
signé dans chaque projet ce sera fini
pour eux alors on a dit ça on a dit
aussi que ce putsch était une tentative
des conservateurs c'est à dire des durs
du parti communiste d'union soviétique
pour vous forcer à choisir le camp des
durs vous étiez hésitant s'allier pu
très bien quoi faire et que ce putsch
était une façon de vous obliger à
prendre le parti des conservateurs vous
répondez quoi à ça et à ce que john est
acheteur sur deux jours et bien cela je
peux vous dire que ce sont des bobards
animale et à d'alliés du carpaccio c'est
parce que ces gens là ne vais pas me
combattre ouvertement jeu tony lee
brimelow garros ils ont payé pour cela
qu'ils ont compris qu'ils allaient
absolue leur seul espoir international
riche en bêta
le reste ce sont des inventions alors
ensuite c'était la chute de l'urss la
chute des pays de l'est
il n'y a jamais eu en urss de procès de
nuremberg comme il
la chute de l'allemagne nazie pour juger
les crimes du stalinisme
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas que
cela n'ait pas été fait dommage pour
mornac procès mais de toutes manières
pas qu'on puisse se mettre un point
d'égalité entre le stalinisme de
fascisme
pour moi ce n'est pas la même chose
l'union soviétique dirigée par staline
d'ailleurs combattu le fascisme
pourquoi les chiens avec d'autres pays
bien entendu vous ne croyez pas que
mourir au goulag
c'est comme mourir à auschwitz
pour moi ce sont deux histoires
différentes que même les primes des
régimes
cela dit impressionné le stalinisme pas
gagné 0,15 insupportable staline imposer
ses vérités avec le goulag plaisir un
marché de masse c'est grâce aux nallet
le pays a été vandalisé oui c'est vrai
qu'il a eu beaucoup d'acquis mais est ce
que le jeu en valait la peine
on a payé pour cela avait créé sur des
murs épais notion yade alors c'est
khrouchtchev qui a commencé à critiquer
est monté ce système et c'est moi qui
achever ce travail
quelle faute reconnaissez vous il
fallait commencer par réformer le parti
communiste poker le parti communiste de
l'urss devenue le principal frein nous
avons mal exprimé
la difficulté des problèmes d'écriture
qui composaient la grèce
il fallait donc reprendre refaire le
traité de l'union bien avant
et enfin la troisième four mowgli sa
critique n'a dit choqué par cette
pratique
il aurait fallu rappeler mon arrêt chez
une des rares à venir frais militaires
de 10 à 15% tout de suite pour racheter
à l'esprit à manger pour l'épauler
population c'est au moment où loge de
mer et les chars attendre pendant des
heures dans les files d'attentes
c'est là que les gens ont dit à quelque
chose qui cloche avec gorbatchev est ce
que le fait par exemple d'avoir minimisé
l'importance de la catastrophe de
tchernobyl n'a pas été une erreur que
vous reconnaissez aujourd'hui oui
j'allais m'acheter on n'a rien minimiser
du tout il ya eu une commission
d'experts cpn les meilleurs spécifique
lions gate envoyés sur place marie et
même ses meilleurs experts leur reprise
au choix pendant deux jours de suite
n'arrivait pas nous dire ce qui s'est
passé parce qu'il y n'y comprenez rien
n'avait rien à dire au monde mais dès
qu'on a appris l'information on
annonçait tout de suite
est-ce que l' aventure en afghanistan
n'a pas été une erreur un chèque si ça a
été une erreur oui bien sûr manière
relâchée prétexte à peristeri choquer
mais je vous rappelle que les leaders de
la pérestroïka moi le premier on a
retiré les trucs ce nombre à nicolas
greliche d'en accepter une décision
difficile croyez moi aujourd'hui nous
les américains s'en sortent mieux que
l'urss en afghanistan dans un ami après
dima je pense que c'était quelque chose
d'indispensable
il fallait la faire il fallait le faire
rire à lille hier ce pays s'est
transformé
de guêpe c'était vraiment un centre de
formation de théories sa libre les
talibans ont refusé de signer son du
conseil de sécurité
ils ont refusé de collaborer avec les
états unis avec un doigté et voyait
mettre fin à cette situation la seule
solution qui vaille à bord est ce que à
rester c'était la solution je le dis si
érogènes cette situation tend à l'après
du président d'un des vertiges kelly les
moyeux leur dire que ce carrefour qhd
rascal ne faut pas croire qu'à chaque
fois c'est de suffit d'envoyer dans un
parti qui joue ici le liban mme pitt et
bien c'est une grande chance en tombant
contre le terrorisme on ne peut pas
adopter les méthodes terroristes quel
sentiment avez vous quand vous voyez la
russie d'aujourd'hui la criminalité la
corruption est ce que vous sentez pas un
peu responsable de ça quand vous voyez
l'espérance de vie en baisse est ce que
finalement c'est terrible à dire mais ce
que finalement les gens vivaient pas
mieux du temps du communisme
louvier le peur de russes à l'heure
actuelle contre les jeunes nourris sur
tous ceux qui ont une petite quarantaine
ne veulent plus retourner vers le
communisme
quand on leur pose la question tout le
pays où vous aimeriez à dix nous allons
vivre dans un pays libre et démocratique
et je pense que c'est c'est la victoire
de la paire historique
ça c'est la même chose nous aimons site
chassera si la russie c'est la corée bio
est libéré etc
mais c'est très réducteur la russie
s'est aussi la nouvelle classe
d'entrepreneurs
c'est l'esprit d'entreprise qui refuse
qu' il est grand monde
est-ce que vous souffrez aujourd'hui de
ne plus être aux affaires est ce que
vous souffrez de ne plus avoir le
pouvoir fait de posséder le power comme
on possède une fin où les oies je n'ai
jamais pour moi une femme toujours été
plus important que nos achats yannick
thomet je ne suis je ne suis pas de ceux
qui me sont arrivées de politique et lui
et lui justement il en cherche on veut
oui il faut réfléchir calmement
alors vous avez changé parce que je
évidemment les premières fissures dans
l' empire soviétique c'était solidarnosc
en pologne lech walesa qui était un ami
de jean paul 2 et vous dites que
l'église catholique et romaine penche à
gauche et que les encyclique du pape
critique la rapacité du capitalisme
c'est assez étonnant de voir ça c'est
aujourd'hui merengue repas de chef qui
dans son livre rend hommage à la
dimension sociale de l'église catholique
attali l'église catholique tout comme
l'église ait de ces églises ont toujours
joué un rôle très important toujours
adopté de position humaniste écouter ce
que dit le pape à l'heure actuelle voilà
quand elle parle de landreau n'y a pas
10 mondial grange et à l'ouvrir oublie
que le l'ordre mondial
nouvel ordre mondial est indispensable
ce régime doit être plus stable il faut
les moments plus équitable et plus
humain voilà ces accords pour des
magnifiques extraordinaire bien alors
votre livre est écrit avec daisaku ikeda
c'est quand même le chef de la soka
gakkai vous savez que la sauver à kayes
c'est une secte ultra riches et
puissantes qui a un revenu annuel de 2
milliards de dollars d actifs de 100
milliards de dollars et 11 millions
d'adeptes dans le monde
est ce que ça vous gêne pas de co signer
un livre avec quelqu'un dont on connaît
mal finalement la finalité des activités
a grandi et maintenant vous savez je
crois que là il y avait pas mal de
choses qui ont été inventés au sujet des
kids à une série d'essais libres et
particulièrement en france je ne sais
pas d'où ça vient et quels en sont les
racines ce livre a été publié dans un
bon nombre de pays déjà ce lit ou re a
été bien embêté par les lecteurs c'est
la première chose et on jamais on va
poser ce genre de questions
maintenant monsieur liquide avant moi à
discuter avec une centaine de
personnalités de tous les coups sûrs nom
est personne n'a jamais c'est vrai
l'accusé liquide et ne lui a jamais
maintenant lui jamais dit qu'il était
responsable l'insee attendait ils ont
tous millions de membres alors en tous
les cas on peut pas dire mikhaïl
gorbatchev que vous vous soyez enrichi
au pouvoir vous au mois votre fortune en
98 est estimée à 2,8 millions de francs
que vous avez déposé dans une banque qui
a fait faillite et vous dites
aujourd'hui les nouveaux riches russes
dépenses en une nuit
ce que je gagne en une année si aurélien
de la mini à problèmes
vironneau cri du coq en fait à l'heure
actuelle j'ai des dettes vis-à-vis d'eux
ma banque la banque qui m'ont accordé
des prêts au moment où j'ai mis en place
ma fondation
il faut continuer le travail ouais mais
où est passé le million de dollars du
prix nobel a presque pris match à
sochaux là et vient en partie n'a pris
1,14 à ce cher brice mach ça a été des
pc pour le projet de aïssa c'est un
centre de lutte contre
avant le signe et sony le reste on y est
j'ai fait construire des stades dans la
région de manille des citoyens
bref ça a été dressé à des fins
d'améliorer elle est hélas les lions 2